bonjour à tous on a beaucoup parlé des
smartphones pliable on attend avec
impatience le samsung galaxy ticks on en
a beaucoup parlé on sait qu'apple dans
la course
les nouveaux huawei motorola tous les
constructeurs s'y mettent petit à petit
les smartphones pliable vont arriver on
va pas pouvoir les louper hélas au delà
des smartphones pliable on va carrément
parler des tablettes pliable alors non
pas un smartphone qui une fois ouvert
pour la taille d'une tablette mais là
vraiment d'une tablette conçue pour une
tablette avec un coup de coude donné
quand même un smartphone et vous allez
voir que super intéressant parce que on
parle pas uniquement d'un produit qui se
plie en deux on parle d'un projet client
3 c'est quelque chose de super
intéressant restez vous inquiétez forme
en parle maintenant
c'est complètement dans cette histoire
de smartphones de tablettes viable c'est
pour moi en tout cas l'avenir de la
téléphonie mobile
on va vers des choses sont toujours plus
réduite plus pratique des choses
modulable on pourra faire énormément de
choses avec et c'est ça qui est vraiment
intéressant c'est l'essence de la
technologie de s'adapter à nos besoins
de s'adapter vraiment à mon mode de vie
à nos modes de consommation alors
aujourd'hui 20 de personnes se disent
quel est l'intérêt d'avoir un smartphone
ou une tablette pliable
si ce n'est juste le point de plier le
mettre dans une poche soit plus petit
mais pour moi en réalité au regard des
objets qui font toujours plus se plier
presque venir un jour invisible du web
des smartphones montrent des choses qui
n'ont vraiment fusionner les uns aux
autres pour que les objets on ne puisse
pas les perdre sera toujours avec nous
en permanence
alors on n'en est pas là il ya beaucoup
de choses qui vont se passer beaucoup
d'eau qui va couler sous les ponts d'ici
là mais là on avance doucement doucement
avec effectivement des écrans qui vont
se plier des choses toujours plus
compacts et là pour le coup même des
tablettes qui vont se plier leur
effectivement ça paraît assez logique de
se dire que c'est les smartphones qui
pipe pour pas les tablettes on pourrait
dire aussi qu'un smartphone plier
devient une tablette s'arrache sens mais
pourquoi pas une tablette qui resterait
une tablette et au lieu de se plier en
un seul et même endroit
on pourrait l'appeler ya plusieurs
endroits et c'est justement justement en
brevets qui a été remarquée déposée par
samsung avec une tablette qui ré se
plier à deux endroits pour plus de
fonctionnalité
un beau mec été remarqué par le site
patently 'mobile' qui repèrent vraiment
les différents brevets intéressant et là
pour le coup c'est vraiment très
intéressant
imaginez vous avez une grande table est
ouverte vous pouvez replié un tiers d'un
côté un tiers de l'autre alors vous me
direz replier pourquoi qu'elle intéresse
abbas appelle ça un vrai super intéressé
à dire que vous repliez une partie ça
vous servent de claviers clavier virtuel
comme un petit ordi voilà qu'on peut
l'imaginer comme ça vous aurez donc
votre écran principal en dessous votre
clavier est au dessus une barre de
notification vous auriez plein de choses
peuvent arriver sur vraiment un côté un
peu pratique ce que j'ai qui ment comme
ça on peut se dire mais ouf pas le truc
vous allez voir qu'une fois pillée vous
allez voir plusieurs configurations une
configuration un peu en or die on peut
imaginer de le décliner les utilités les
utilisations à l'infini pense
effectivement il y aura utilisation de
base avec l' os mais on peut imaginer
que des développeurs vraiment s'amuser à
intégrer plein de choses pas ne concéder
que ce soit sur du confessionnal être
sûr du gaming et celle quelque chose de
vraiment très intéressant
autre intérêt cette tablette c'est qu'on
pourra passer des coups de fil avec donc
effectivement une tablette qui devient
une espèce de fable est géante un
smartphone parce que c'est effectivement
le prendre des tablettes aujourd'hui
vous prenez un ipad vous le coller sur
la tête là franchement pour pas sa
boutique spartacus gens pas trop
l'intérêt
mais demain vous pourriez le faire avec
cette tablette sa effectivement ont
toujours une grosse fable est mais en
tout cas ça pourrait être pas mal
la question à se poser c'est est ce que
c'est vraiment un produit fini qui
pourrait sortir comme ça ou alors est-ce
que ça serait une alternative aux
galaxies xs que d'un côté samsung n'est
pas en train de tester un autre produit
vers lequel point que le plus
intéressant parce que vous savez des
brevets les fabricants repose beaucoup
et il n'y a pas forcément de produits
finis qui sort barrière là par contre je
trouve vraiment intéressant c'est la
vision de ce que pourrait être la
tablette du futur parce que comme je
vous le dis une tablette s'est jamais
rien que l'espèce de petit moniteur sans
que sont alliés sans rien mis à part les
ehpad propos des choses comme ça on est
des petits claviers
mais là pour le coup vous pourriez avoir
un clavier vraiment intégré pour imager
d'avoir plein d'autres choses avec plein
d'autres fonctionnalités
est ce que c'est une vraie piste pour
être une tablette est ce que c'est une
piste pourrait être une alternative aux
galaxies x voilà on sait pas trop où est
ce que ce produit vers un jour un jour
ou l'autre on sait pas non plus mais en
tout cas ce qui est vraiment intéressant
c'est que quand on a parlé des
smartphones pliable et notamment du
galaxy s s'est toujours posé la question
de dire comment ils vont se plier et au
final l'idée de base c'est qu'il y
aurait un seul endroit pour le plier là
si on peut multiplier les zones pour le
plier de compliqué on pourrait imaginer
qu'il souffre comme un bouquin vous
aurez une partie une deuxième partie
sauf une grande tablette vous êtes une
seule partie tels turin en bout d'écran
sur la surface
on peut vraiment imaginer les choses
infinies alors l'idée serait d'avoir
depuis dans tous les sens depuis un an
quatre cinq six sept perdre un petit peu
l'essence du produit puisse atteindre a
tout compliqué peut-être même un peu
fragile au bout de mon nom mais de
pouvoir imaginer ce genre de choses avec
une partie qui sert de clavier qui peut
servir de plein d'autres choses je
trouve que ça a un vrai sens alors
apprendre plus demandés aussi est ce que
ça te ra pas doublon
si on a une grosse tablette qui fait
téléphone et de l'autre côté un
smartphone qu'on peut aussi agrandir
qu'il fait comme une petite fable est
est-ce qu'on va pas voir les deux
produits qui vont marcher sur les
plates-bandes de l'autre et
réciproquement
j'ai pas persuadé d'autant plus
qu'aujourd'hui le marché et pas de but
ou matures pas du tout le mur donc on
est vraiment qu'au début les
constructeurs test différentes solutions
mais c'est vrai qu'à l'avenir on peut
vraiment voir ce à savoir un sens et on
peut même après l'imaginer sur des
ordinateurs avec un peu plus depuis
pourquoi pas avoir effectivement quelque
chose qui va se bouger qui peut se
tourner un peu dans tous les sens bon
allez tout c'est un peu une nébuleuse de
pouvoir imaginer ce qu'on peut faire
mais réfléchissez à ce que vous faites
de votre ordinateur si vous n'êtes pas
en des créatifs des graphistes est ce
que ça pourrait avoir un sens si vous
êtes développeur est ce que ça pourrait
avoir un sens d'aller développer quelque
chose de pas être plus interactif avec
ce côté de publier ça peut être pas mal
en tout cas ce qu'on voit au travers de
ce brevet c'est que on en est qu'au
début les questions se posent de tous
les côtés comment plier à quoi ça sert
les fonctionnalités l'intérêt public
ce qu'on voit derrière c'est
qu'effectivement toutes ces grandes
marques tous ces géants de la
technologie que soit samsung apple et
tous les autres se posent toujours des
questions sont en train de regarder
vraiment à l'avenir regarder beaucoup
plus loin à l'horizon qu est-ce qu au
final pourrait apporter la technologie
et en quoi les techno comme ces écrans
pliables vont pouvoir améliorer et
faciliter notre quotidien demain
pourrait également dire qu'ils sont en
train de créer des besoins mais au final
qui sont pas en train de répondre à des
problématiques qu'on ne connaît même pas
aujourd'hui pour faciliter notre avenir
parce que si on va par là il ya encore
une dizaine d'années les smartphones
n'existait pas si on recule encore plus
ans passés il ya vingt ans en arrière 25
ans on n'avait pas tous des téléphones
portables et aujourd'hui ça paraît quand
même un petit peu incontournable alors
effectivement des fois on y va un peu
trop loin trop sont les applications pro
guides seront enfermés mais si on lève
un peu la tête qu'on prend un peu de
recul par rapport à ça ça reste quand
même un super outil qui nous permet de
rester connecté au monde entier partout
on est d'être en permanence connectés
aux gens qui compte que ce soit nos
enfants nos parents nos amis sans en
aviser une fois de plus l'idée c'est pas
ça mais l'idée est effectivement qu'on
vaut travers de ses écrans pliables de
l'avenir de ce que pourraient être ses
smartphones c'est qu'on va aller encore
plus loin dans le fait de nous relier
les uns aux autres et de faire que les
choses soient plus simple donc
aujourd'hui peut paraître complètement
futile de se dire à quoi serviront des
écrans pliables et peut-être que ces
écrans pliables une fois qu'on les aura
vus et qu'on aura vraiment créer un
intérêt on se rend compte qu'il ya un
vrai besoin et qu'au final c'est super
pertinents autrefois qui est intéressant
c'est que de renouvellement des
tablettes est quand même beaucoup moins
élevé que celui des smartphones
on peut imaginer des renouvellements à 2
trois ans voir un petit peu plus est là
il n'était pas plus mal parce que c'est
pas une fois de plus ça coûte cher et
doit pas être vue écologique
ça coûte aussi cher à l'environnement
donc ont renouvelé sa tablette prend
beaucoup plus de temps s'ils nous
sortent des tablettes avec des écrans
pliables ça pourrait booster le marché
et faire qui est un petit peu plus de
ventes et que ça dynamise un petit peu
ce secteur d'activité alors on peut se
poser la question est ce que c'est bien
pas bien voilà en tout cas moi je pense
en tout cas ce truc là est vraiment
hyper intéressant et on va s'y pencher
de plus en plus croyez moi voilà un
petit peu ce qu'on peut dire aujourd'hui
sur cette tablette à double partie
pliable de samsung
restez connectés abonnez vous parce que
vous allez voir on va beaucoup en
parlent à l'avenir et c'est des choses
qui devraient arriver tout doucement
probablement en 2019
donc on va rester sur les pistes on va
fouiller à notre égard à droite à gauche
voir un peu ce qui se profile à
l'horizon
donc restez connectés une fois de plus
de 8 à de laisser toutes vos questions
suggestions commentaires directement en
bas en dessous là vous ne marquez tout
ça et puis on interagit comme ça c'est
sympa c'est pas mais effectivement de
partager un peu l'expérience je vous
invite à me laisser des jolies pousse à
vous abonner on reste connectés je vous
dis à très bientôt soyez sages je vous
embrasse
et d'ici là rendez-vous bien tiens
[Musique]